a lot of prejudice where i'm from a lot
of people i was jewish growing up any
jews here
hey all right
just enough
just kidding
you're the one good to have you all
right yeah
love the jews jews are fun you know why
jews are fun it's the only religion
you'd use as an adjective yeah you'd be
like oh yeah jeff's got curly hair very
nervous kind of jewy yeah
you could never do that with any other
religion now you're gonna be like oh
yeah bob he won't let his wife drive
kind of muzzy
makes her cover her face big old muzz
that guy yes
huge muslim
yes yeah but you know growing up in
louisiana these these southern boys
they'd be like hey man you a jew and i
was like me no and they're like good
we're not crazy about the jews
it's like wow it must be weird to hate
something you can't even point out
you know if you have to ask you're just
bad at being racist
it must be frustrating to hate jews if
you hate jews you must sit on a bus
staring at somebody like
i think i hate that guy
pretty sure i hate him i'll tell you if
then
they're not wearing little hats i am
clueless
that's one thing i learned about myself
moving to new york i learned i love
jewish women oh boy you guys drive me
wild i don't care about the religion
part i just love a big
jew face on a lady oh boy
yeah it makes my knees buckle i'll tell
ya
yes
i was actually lucky enough to date a
jewish girl for a while we talked about
getting married and her dad made us
break up because i'm not jewish and i
was like come on really seriously like i
live in new york i have curly hair i'm
circumcised i'm a comedian i'm like
right there
but still still he was like no no my
daughter will only marry a jew out my
people to live on my culture live on
jews are all about living on that's when
i thought man jews must be really
jealous of gay people because gay people
can't even
reproduce yet they keep popping up
that's amazing that's incredible no
other group can do that it's like a
super power you know
you're like jews are sitting around like
you got to marry jew you've got to marry
jew and gays are like
we'll be fine
yeah
all right